andrew garfield is continuing his
eventful uh thanksgiving for god's sake
stewart for tick tick boom with the most
heartwarming reaction to a little
surprise from netflix yes so about a
month ago andrew confessed to being
obsessed with cobra kai on netflix
during an interview segment called
netflix geeks take a look at this
in new york you you relayed some details
about the netflix show that you really
love
kobrik high
became
an obsession and i've had to put it on
the shelf because you have not given us
season
four yet
ah
i love that coprice i haven't actually
gotten into that show yet it's good okay
now this just makes my heart melt so
after andrew's admission he got a very
special shout out from the cast and
andrew admitted it felt like christmas
which is so cute take a look
we were able to get some time with some
people that wanted to send me
no hey andrew oscar andrew garfield
[Music]
what's up hey andrew it's billy zapkin
ralph lacio coming from the set of cobra
kai i am mary mouser i play samantha
larusso on cobra kai which hopefully you
know that since you say you're such a
big fan um which is so freaking cool
that's freaking awesome that you are a
fan of the show that's super super cool
that's so nice we were so stoked to hear
that brother all the best no mercy no
more
a little bit of balance there a little
bit of balance i had so much balance
i love you guys
bye miyagido for life
[Music]
come on oh my god
no i can't handle it
he didn't prepare me i was like what are
you what are we doing and then you do
that and then you have william zobka and
you have ralph macchio i'm like oh no
they know that i exist
it's christmas feels like christmas in
my body my body feels like christmas
forget the season four that like that's
gonna keep me going for years that was
thank you i'm very very moved and
touched by that gosh
oh it's so great we need to protect andy
garfield at all costs that was such an
honest vulnerable moment for him is
there a cast of a show right now that
you're obsessed with or even from the
past that if they gave you a shout out
you would say that it feels like
christmas oh
god yeah you know what i
okay oh my god bear with bear with me on
this yes i
like i have two people
that i if they gave me a shout out i
think that i would die and i'm not like
fanboy of really anything i know you're
not okay one is um michael from love on
the spectrum
okay me and him would be best friends
love on the spectrum i don't know that
one okay it's a it's a fantastic show
reality dating show
on netflix about uh adults who are on
the autism spectrum
he is the greatest television character
i have seen in my life i love him
michael michael okay i love him i love
him so much also larry david oh yeah
that's a good so if it was the cast if
if larry and susie told me off in a
video i think that that would probably
be my you'd be done i would be done i
would quit i would you would not see me
uh tomorrow i think that yeah okay uh
i'm gonna be honest and listen it's fine
i've been this way since i was 15 but
dawson's creek is like my ultimate
favorite show of all time i watch it
when i'm down when i've had a breakup
when i'm happy like it is like my go-to
comfort show of all time so if anybody
including
pacey witter i was gonna say dawson or
pacey okay okay okay okay that's not
even a question um so it would be
i would die or um currently right now
i'm loving jenny and georgia jenny and
george i've seen it okay so many times
if anybody on that show were to give me
like ginny or georgia i would freak that
would be so cool because i want to be
friends with them i want to hang out at
yellowstone that's what i want to do
just got into that i want to hang out
there yeah i want to go i don't want to
like get cool i don't want to you
wouldn't be a cowboy i don't want to get
into a fight with anybody i don't want
to have to fight rip but i just want to
like drive trucks and like what about
ride ride a horse i don't know i don't
ride horses oh too dangerous okay um i
just want to like
i don't know how you fit in try trucks
and hang out
you know what a beard i can see you with
the hats
just give them some pictures uh but yeah
i know andrew garfield is the uh i love
watching people who andrew garfield has
seen that exact same reaction and
countless fans who have met him of
course and it's always it's always
wonderful to see that same reaction that
i'm sure he is more than used to sort of
in his own uh in his own face that's
great yeah fulani saying how cute to see
a famous actor acting like we regular
people would act if we got a shout out
from our faves nicole's saying i just
love andrew's interviews lately he's all
hearts misha sang she would basically
freak out of the cast of full house uh
gave her a shout out vanessa's saying
can reason alex winter bill and ted if
they gave her a shout out that would be
amazing that'd be pretty cool uh yeah
and and honestly andrew is doing so many
interviews right now he recently opened
up about losing his mom before shooting
tick tick boom i mean none of us really
knew that so i just think he's uh i'm a
huge fan